there will be much to mull over in
coming days about the robert muller
report and the Attorney General's
four-page letter about it but it's
clearly a political win and a legal win
for the president and his team the
Muller report by the numbers 19 lawyers
40 FBI agents intelligence analysts
interviewed 500 witnesses issued more
than 2,800 subpoenas executed nearly 500
search warrants in the end 34
individuals and three companies were
indicted on 199 charges more than two
dozen of them Russians in an internet
forum in total the 675 day investigation
cost more than 25 million dollars let's
bring in our panel Kimberley's Rasul a
member of the editorial board at The
Wall Street Journal Charles Lane an
opinion writer for The Washington Post
and Viktor David Hansen a senior fellow
at the Hoover Institution and author of
the new book the case for Trump Viktor
first do you wrap up this weekend in the
news about the report and as you see it
well I think we have to realize that
Hillary Clinton had have just won the
election and she had not hired a foreign
national to collect dirt on her campaign
appoint we wouldn't be talking today the
entire collusion narrative grew out of
the disappointment of trying to explain
the inexplicable why she lost and then
the dossier transmogrified some
insurance to help the landslide into a
way to abort the trump presidency second
thing I think they thought collusion was
separate from all these process climbs
and obstruction and once the collusion
narrative us I think most people thought
didn't exist once it failed how can you
really obstruct justice for a crime that
didn't exist if Donald Trump said
something about the futility or the
waste of the collusion narrative it
would be seen post facto as wise
jurisprudence trying to warn people
don't do something stupid it's not
obstruction to do that finally
everything that begins badly ends badly
Brett I mean the idea that rod
Rosenstein who had signed the FISA Court
one of the FISA Court writs that was
misleading and had given the rationale
to file fire James Comey and had been in
this tragic comic circus with McCabe
right before
was appointed some kind of palace coup
was going to be disinterested in a way
that Jeff Sessions was not as the
overseer was crazy and then finally when
this team was appointed the left and the
nevertrump right said they went giddy
it was the All Stars the Dream Team the
untouchables the hunter-killer team the
reason they did that is that Robert
Mueller didn't exercise just basic
caution he could have just said whatever
the law or the protocol is I want an
equal mixture of conservative and
liberal lawyers I want to make sure that
nobody on this team has given either to
the Trump campaign or to the Clinton
campaign I want to make sure that none
of you on government devices if you were
working for the government has said
anything pro Trump or anti Trump and
then finally he could have said just
don't I don't want anybody in my team
that's donated to either campaign had he
done that at the very beginning it would
have been different now he's got a
reputation of a Captain Ahab or maybe
Inspector Javert right out of labor
mizerock I referenced it with Britt
earlier but the CIA director former CIA
director John Brennan had some
interesting things just days ago to say
about all of this and then talk today on
MSNBC take a listen
Friday's the day that the grand jury
indictments come down I don't think
Robert Muller will want to have that
dramatic flair of the Ides of March when
he is going to be delivering what I
think are gonna be his indictments the
final indictments I know if I received
bad information but I think I suspected
that there was more than there actually
was and I am relieved that there has
been determined that there was not a
criminal conspiracy with the Russian
government over our election I think
that is good news for the country Chuck
I said earlier the legal threat is not
done for the president with the southern
digit of New York and the investigations
on Capitol Hill there'll be a lot of
battle over what obstruction means on on
Capitol Hill but your thoughts well I
don't know what the CIA director was
talking about the first time and I don't
really know what he's talking about the
second time he didn't really know what
he was talking about and that's too bad
I think that was probably a mistake on
his part given the
prestige of the former office that he
carried but I do agree with him that it
is to the extent we have now shown there
was no criminal conspiracy that ought to
be something that everybody can agree on
is a good thing it is not a good thing
that Russia did attempt to distort
disrupt however you want to call it
interfere with our elections are using
social media and accentuating the
divisions in our country and I guess I
have to disagree with what what Victor
Davis Hanson said which is that I don't
think Muller has I don't think Muller's
reputations been damaged here and I
don't think the fact that his team was
perhaps you know filled with a bunch of
people who were supposedly Democrats is
in hindsight a black mark if anything
that fortifies the president's position
right now which is like you know even
this guy who was Inspector Javert
couldn't find collusion on him the
dangling piece here is that no
exoneration on obstruction but I think
the Democrats have to think really
carefully about pursuing that because
that gets into relitigated the whole
Comey firing which is ultimately
supposedly the source of the obstruction
and that leads down a very very deep
rabbit hole and I think you know speaker
Pelosi has has said we're not going to
impeach and if you're not going to
impeach what's the point of pursuing
that obstruction so that's a tough one
for them Kimberly we found out today
that the Attorney General found out
three weeks prior to the report coming
out that that Muller was not going to
reach a conclusion on obstruction that
surprise both bar and Rosenstein we
heard Alan Dershowitz and others say
they should have yes or no come to a
conclusion instead of putting things in
that report your thoughts we've got the
other panel after this to talk about it
as well yeah look I do think there are
some interesting questions about how
Muller handled this on the one hand you
could say that tossing it to the
Attorney General was at least putting
that question in the hands of someone
with some political accountability and
then obviously one of the knocks against
the special counsel is that he's not
necessarily political accountable nobody
elected him nobody confirmed him on the
other hand you could wonder if it was a
bit of a wimpy thing to just toss that
off to the AG
and leave it with them but on a broader
point look I think Chuck makes a good
valid one legally from an obstruction
perspective the president has a win here
because no one is going to pursue from a
position of authority obstruction
charges now if Democrats want to make
the political case for why that's wrong
they're welcome to but again even in
light of this news that you just
mentioned one of their complaints for
instance was that bar had rushed to
judgment on the obstruction question
well that's clearly a false narrative
because he has been in possession of
this information for three weeks
moreover we found out that he consulted
with career officials at the office of
legal counsel in making the decision not
to pursue obstruction